guys it is that time of year my top 10
worst films of 2015 and since we're
talking about some butt-ugly movies I
wore a butt ugly sweater I hope you like
it guys this year was one of the most
anticipated years in a long time tons of
huge movies were gonna be out this year
a lot of people are really excited about
2015 and in some ways some films really
did deliver these 10 films whole they
really didn't before I mentioned my pick
for number 10 I have a couple
dishonorable mentions these are movies
that were so terrible but didn't quite
make the list
the gunmen Wow Sean Penn has muscles
everyone look at Sean Penn's muscles
he's got the muscles who gives a shit
man your movie sucked and Point Break an
absolutely unnecessary remake of a
perfectly fun nineties action movie that
was really just an X Games movie
masquerading as a remake of Point Break
and man did I hate it and the next 10
are even worse number 10 taken 3 why
does this movie exist it exists purely
to be a trilogy there's no reason for
taking free to exist
maybe it's because taken to made a shit
ton of money
why did taken to make so much money
because the first one was actually good
they took the same director from taken
two and made a shaky incomprehensible
mess of an action movie
hitman agent 47 or as I like to call it
a feature-length commercial for Audi
cars the first one sucked and didn't do
well so they decided to make the exact
same film again with a different actor
because they thought apparently if they
did the exact same thing that failed
first again that for some reason it
would be successful the second time it
wasn't I had to watch that in theaters
with other people if there was one word
to describe Hot Pursuit it would be
annoying it is without a doubt the most
annoying film I sat through this entire
year Reese Witherspoon dragging Sophia
Vergara
around Witherspoon played a plucky very
persistent cop and Sofia Vergara was
just Sofia Vergara
oh my Shyam I dress all my boobs that's
the whole movie I'm serious and it
really worked I mean I was on the edge
of my seat because I was half asleep and
I almost fell out of my seat
Jupiter ascending and this is a movie
I'm actually sad to say is on this list
because it was an attempt at making an
original science fiction movie they
actually tried to make an original
different sci-fi action movie there were
cows key siblings and man did they fail
it felt like you had to read a 10,000
page long dictionary to understand the
plot Jupiter Jones was a terrible hero
she didn't do anything she had to be
rescued every other scene by Channing
Tatum who looked hilarious in wolf ears
or something this movie was so bad Tatum
didn't even want to promote it Outkast
did anyone see this movie I did Nicolas
Cage and Hayden Christensen in a
straight to video on-demand movie well
that's all you need to know right there
the only thing this movie has going
forward is an incredibly over-the-top
Nicolas Cage performance that was
awesome to see and entertaining in is so
bad that it's good way the rest of the
movie was a poorly shot hyper actively
edited disgusting looking movie with
Hayden Christensen really trying to act
and failing Paranormal Activity the
ghost dimension or Paranormal Activity 6
if you want to call it that look this
movie was so bad I didn't even sit down
and do a traditional review I did a
video called thoughts on Paranormal
Activity the ghost dimension it was a
one take video in which it was just my
inner thoughts after leaving this film
you guys loved it I had a ton of fun
making that video and it was my perfect
way to describe how terrible this movie
was inside I didn't even feel like
talking about it and then I realized
just make a video out of that make a
video about how much you don't want to
review it but while you're doing that
you're reviewing it in your brain and
you guys loved it I had a lot of fun
making it horror fans out there like
myself if you like this movie that's
fine but you've got to acknowledge what
that movie was just another attempt to
milk some more money out of your pockets
just to see if they could make any more
the boy next door
starring Jennifer Lopez as an English
literature professor this movie was
directed by Rob Cohen who brought us
great films like stealth and Alex Cross
it was about a 40-something teacher who
falls for a 19 year old student who
moves in next door has sex with him and
then he becomes a crazy psychopath my
gosh I hated this movie it was just
filled with Hollywood cliches pixles
starring Adam Sandler and all his
friends guys I'm the biggest retro gamer
I love retro games I grew up playing a
lot of the games that this movie is
paying homage to and my god that I hated
Kevin James as the President of the
United States I mean the movie lost me
would Adam Sandler and Michelle Monaghan
got together Kevin James going to fuck
the president whoa whoa whoops I drop
something off oh oh I'm so happy I'm
Adam Sandler's friend where's Rob
Schneider and to all the people that
told me that pixels is actually a good
movie I'm glad you enjoyed it I don't
know what to say to that though I
thought about these next two films very
carefully because I hated both of them
and I thought which film if I were
forced would I want to watch more than
the other it's really hard
vant for stick I refuse to call this
movie what they want me to call it it's
fit for stick look maybe for like the
first 40 minutes of this movie it's just
bad it's not awful but it's just bad and
a lot of people were like oh this
movie's not that bad it's not that great
oh oh
from the second the words one year later
appear on screen in Fant four stick this
movie turns into an absolute disaster I
mean it was terrible you can see poor
Kate
aras wig changing in and out as they do
reshoots it's atrocious it's so bad the
third act of this movie is a
green-screen mess with somebody dressed
sort of like Doctor Doom but it's kind
of like a cosplay Doctor Doom like
somebody in their basement made an okay
costume that would look amazing at Comic
Con and shit in a Hollywood movie I
hated it
just drop it with these characters Fant
for stick you failed you're the fourth
one in a row to do it we're done and now
it's that time my most hated film of
2015 the one film that I just can never
imagine watching again and that would be
Fifty Shades of Grey
I apologize I almost died saying that
name again it's not just a movie that I
hated so much it's the entire thing
surrounding Fifty Shades of Grey an
author writing a Twilight fan fiction
and then changing the names and certain
locations to adapt it into her own fan
fiction then that becoming a novel
filled with grammatical errors and
terrible writing and then that becoming
a movie and me sitting in a theater with
a bunch of middle-aged women who at
times did moan I'm not kidding the air
in that theater was humid I felt sick to
my stomach
it was disgusting it is the very thing
that I hate about movies oh it's a
popular thing that thing definitely
sucks and we know it sucks but hey we
can make some money off of it we'll make
it a movie and we'll make two more who
knows maybe we'll make three morons but
the last book in the two parts yay
the best word I can pick to describe
this movie going experience was awkward
I hated every second of it we have a
male star who didn't even want to be in
the nude how do you hire a male actor
for a movie like this who doesn't want
any nudity that's crazy and our lead
character played by Dakota Johnson was
one
weakest characters of cinema this entire
year she doesn't even like BDSM and she
just keeps letting them do it to her it
keeps going back to him because it's all
she can think about because you know I
don't know fucking Twilight shit man I
hated that movie huh I don't ever have
to talk about those movies again guys
those are my picks for the worst movies
of 2015 what are yours I want know tell
me what are your worst theater going
experiences this year I want to know
below guys 2015 was great I just want to
personally thank you for taking this
ride with me for yet another year I've
had a great time doing it you guys are
the best
I will see you in 2016 have a good one
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes